[Música]
[Aplausos]
amor então também acaba não que eu saiba
eu sei que ele se transforma numa
matéria prima que a vida se encarrega de
transformar em raiva ou em rima
quando o amor se transforma em rima vir
uma poesia como essa linda do leminski e
quando se transforma em raiva ver um
processo na maioria das vezes e acaba
numa vara de família e eu sou juíza há
quase 23 anos
desses 23 anos 16
eu passei em uma vara de família e era
ali naquele espaço onde eu conseguia
assistir com uma uma espectadora
privilegiada o desenlace do fim do amor
e ficava muito angustiado e muito
perplexa porque como é que você pode
falar de justiça quando o amor acaba
as pessoas vivem numa sociedade nós
vivemos numa sociedade que cultuam amor
idealizado um amor romântico um amor até
que a morte nos separe
e todas as vezes que nos confrontamos
com algumas contrariedades ou com o
término de um projecto que resulta no
fim do amor
a frustração é muito grande ea
expectativa de quem chega numa vara de
família é uma expectativa muito dolorosa
porque o amor nunca acaba
ao mesmo tempo para os dois ou
dificilmente isso acontece
ninguém está tomando café às 7 horas da
manhã e um olha para o outro fala é
nosso amor acabou
que coincidência que o amor não é assim
que acontece
o amor acaba e nem sempre acaba ao mesmo
tempo e aquele que é comunicado do fim
do amor quando chega a justiça espera
que o juiz seja justo e o que significa
para o juiz e justo no fim do amor para
aquela pessoa significa restabelecer
é certo que não volta mais e a
frustração é muito grande e as mágoas
são muito grandes e o desfile das
tragédias rotineiramente diante dos meus
olhos e me fizeram perceber angústia que
é você ter um lugar de poder que é um
lugar de juiz e não poder ser aquelas
pessoas na experiência daquela dor que é
tão individual
eu realizei nesses 16 anos seguramente
mais de 20 mil audiências e não havia
uma audiência em que eu terminava o meu
trabalho achando que tinha conseguido um
resultado pelo menos satisfatório para
aliviar aquelas dores daquelas pessoas
que procuravam a justiça como que
pedindo uma autorização para poder viver
o fim do amor sem tanta dor e sem tanta
tristeza ea última oportunidade também
de acompanhar durante esse período a
transformação profunda pela qual passou
a sociedade especialmente as famílias
nesses últimos anos porque poucas
instituições mudaram tanto quanto as
famílias
para vocês terem uma idéia até 1977 o
divórcio era proibido no brasil as
pessoas morriam casadas e infelizes
até 1988 ea gente está falando de ontem
um homem casado que tivesse um filho
fora do casamento era proibido de
realizar o registro desse filho porque a
constituição protegia o casamento e os
filhos eram tratados de maneira
diferente
felizmente as relações mudaram e na
maioria das vezes mudaram para melhor
hoje as relações afetivas familiares são
mais plurais são mais horizontais são
mais democráticas mas como nada na vida
é plano também padecemos de relações
mais rasas e tive oportunidade de
acompanhar ruptura dessas formas de se
relacionar ao longo do
é um pouco quando pela primeira vez eu
recebi um casal muito jovem zezinho para
divorciar
eles haviam casado há três meses e
chegaram na audiência para fazer o
divórcio recente disse mus um mau olhava
pro outro e os lances tem certeza que
vocês querem de você a um casamento não
era bem o que a gente esperava que se
esperavam que fosse um casamento
e aí você percebe o confronto que há
entre a expectativa que se cria motivada
e turbinada por essa sociedade de
consumo ea realidade porque casamento
idealizado é aquele que toca música
o casal tem trilha sonora no café da
manhã na cama as pessoas acordam de bom
humor
ninguém põe a mesa ninguém tira a toalha
de cima da cama eo cotidiano acontece
sem que ninguém tenha que fazer nada sem
que nenhuma contrariedades possa ser
experimentada
então quando a gente começa a perceber a
chegada na justiça de uma geração que
cresceu sem aprender a ser contrariada e
que a primeira contrariedades é um luto
provocado pelo fim do amor a gente
começa a refletir assim o caminho que a
gente está trilhando e que tipo de
sociedade que a gente pretende
incensando valores que não são de fato
valores que digam respeito a humanidade
porque ninguém precisa viver no inferno
pra ficar casado ninguém é obrigado a se
submeter a um outro nome do outro mas há
regras de convívio de cuidado e de
responsabilidade e especialmente de
afeto que se não forem trabalhados e
cuidadas elas não são atributos naturais
da humanidade ea justiça nesse contexto
eu percebi que eu conseguia fazer isso
durante as audiências agregar esses
valores de cultura de arte de justiça e
de educação que são todos os valores que
nascem da mesma raiz da humanidade
e talvez a minha experiência anterior à
magistratura tenha me ajudado muito
porque antes de ser juíza eu fui
roteirista de cinema e foi produtora de
teatro e muitas vezes nas audiências eu
precisei me socorrer da ficção para
poder mostrar para alguns casais que
otelo de shakespeare um ciumento sofria
de uma patologia que ele conseguia
enxergar na ficção mas não enxergava na
própria vida
outras vezes eu interrompi a audiência
corria no computador e pescava algum
texto do roland barthes do fragmentos de
um discurso amoroso que é quase uma uma
bíblia para aqueles casais que se
relacionam se apaixonam e separo então
foi possível usar a ficção referências
de filme referências de de livro
referências mitológicas para que aquelas
pessoas enxergassem como naturalmente
vítimas de dores que são naturais da
própria humanidade
tolstoi tem uma frase que ele diz que as
famílias felizes parecem se todas e que
as infelizes são infelizes cada uma à
sua maneira
claro que ele escreveu isso como um
super autor que é mas se ele fosse juiz
de família seguramente ele mudaria um
pouco essa frase por que tantas famílias
felizes quanto às famílias infelizes são
profundamente diferentes e um juiz
precisa entender que a dor experimentada
por aquelas pessoas é individual juiz de
família que não gosta de gente que não
tem vontade de compreender a contradição
que é a nossa condição humana não deve
ser juiz de família porque nós somos
seres precários errantes contraditórios
erramos muitas vezes acertamos outras e
o que temos em comum é exatamente essa
humanidade tão densa tão forte e que nos
faz afirmar o afeto apesar de todos os
percalços
e apesar da percepção que o amor
um dia chega ao fim conduzir essas
audiências de uma maneira mais humana
tentando entender o que cada um tinha
para dizer do seu lugar foi extremamente
útil
primeiro para aplacar a minha angústia
diante da incapacidade de resolver
aqueles conflitos
depois porque eu percebi que as pessoas
quando se sentiam autorizadas a ser
menos perfeitas e - idealizados elas
conseguiam vivenciar o luto ea tristeza
com mais autonomia porque essa mesma
sociedade que idealiza aquela família
linda da fotografia da margarina aquela
família que todo mundo é feliz o tempo
todo essa mesma sociedade exige de nós
uma felicidade permanente euforia
perpétua que é incompatível com a nossa
condição humana
então é como se um juiz autorizasse
alguém ao direito de vivenciar a
tristeza ea dor que são naturais que
passam mas que são naturais e aconteceu
que numa determinada audiência
isso não é comum porque normalmente quem
procura a justiça que a solução rápida
quem procura a justiça que é uma
sentença que é uma decisão e acontecia
muitas vezes eu precisar perder um longo
tempo para que aquele casal tivesse a
possibilidade de vomitar os
ressentimentos de trazer as sobras do
amor por uma sala de audiência que é um
espaço que historicamente não é feito
para isso não é desenhado para isso mas
que muitas vezes é o único espaço onde
aquelas pessoas conseguem conversar e
conseguem buscar alternativas não para
as grandes questões da separação mas
para as questões mais banais e que
importam muito pouco para os números e
para as estatísticas como é que você
arruma a mala e sai de casa
que horas que você dê
a parta o paletó do vestido o que você
faz com livro quando ele autografado
para o casal e o autor é uma paixão do
casal
quem fica com essas sobras
como é que você administra esse
cotidiano
então às vezes era preciso estender um
pouco tempo das audiências para tentar
entender que tipo de conflito era aquele
e que tipo de expectativa era que ela
que chegava na minha vara para uma
decisão
e aconteceu uma história que me tocou
profundamente que era uma história que
na audiência chegou uma mãe pedindo a
guarda de três filhos e ela havia saído
de casa quatro anos e não teve mais
contato com essas crianças e muito tenso
ambiente tudo muito difícil o pai não
queria de jeito nenhum que ela ficasse
com a guarda dos filhos porque segundo
ele ela teria abandonado os filhos
durante esse período e agora voltou para
buscar ea história que é a mãe era
doente ela teve uma crise profunda
depressão e precisou se ausentar de casa
para se tratar e depois de quatro anos
um pouco melhores já reabilitadas sobre
terapia quis voltar e assumir a relação
o pai existia e eu achava uma loucura
aquele homem ser tão duro porque ninguém
sabe como vai responsabilizar uma pessoa
porque ela sofreu em uma doença teve
depressão domingo dava pra você
responsabilizar a mulher mais do que ela
já havia sofrido com a doença ea
história continuou rolando ea final no
meio da audiência vem a revelação de que
ele já estava com outra mulher
aí eu fui ficando com mais raiva ainda
aflige nossa como é que pode até não
abandona a mulher com depressão não quer
deixar mais aproximado os filhos e ainda
por cima está com outra mulher e todas
as histórias que chegam na vara de
família tem muitas versões e é um lugar
onde eu aprendi a julgar muito poucas
pessoas porque eu aprendi que não
andar não é possível julgar sem ouvir e
aí vem a versão do pai
aquela mãe tinha uma depressão crônica
há mais de dez anos e ele sempre cuidou
da mulher durante todo esse período ele
trabalhava embarcado ele se virava para
dar conta das crises da mulher das
crianças nunca ocupou a família da
mulher com nada até que um dia ele
chegou em casa as crianças estavam há
três dias sem comer ea mulher devastada
e ele não tinha mais a quem pedir ajuda
ligou para a sogra pediu para a sogra
levar a mulher e o tempo seguiu ele se
organizou continuou cuidando dos filhos
e se afastou ela foi fazer o tratamento
não voltou mais ao convívio nem a
procurar ou como parte do tratamento por
falta de vontade não ficou claro
mas o fato é que ele não pediu o
divórcio dela porque ela precisava do
plano de saúde que ele tinha e ele não
teve coragem de romper um vínculo e
manteve o plano de saúde para que ela
pudesse se tratar
então não era uma história de muitos
amores era uma história de uma tragédia
onde todo mundo tinha razão na sua
perspectiva e esse processo demorou uns
dois anos porque eu conseguia marcar
audiências a cada três meses com a
presença das crianças com a
reaproximação das crianças com a
tentativa de trazer a mãe novamente para
aquele ambiente familiar e no final de
dois anos aguarda finalmente foi
compartilhada eles divorciar um e cada
um foi viver ali cuidando dos seus
filhos porque parentalidade
conjugalidade são coisas diferentes
então arranjos que não dependem só de
uma decisão dependem da escuta e
dependem de tempo e se durante muitos
anos eu fui responsável por observar
repo decidir vários processos desses de
desamor e de separação
eu também tive a felicidade de realizar
muitos casamentos porque como juíza de
família tiver sorte de poder realizar
casamentos que eu adoro e sempre nesses
casamentos a partir dessa experiência
que eu tive
dessas rupturas por frustrações
idealizações e promessas não cumpridas
o meu cuidado era que os noivos se
prometer sem uns aos outros não um amor
eterno um amor eterno um amor do até que
a morte nos separe fidelidade pra vida
toda
monopólio da sexualidade não o que eu
pedia era que um prometer se para o
outro o cuidado diário com afeto com a
responsabilidade e com a certeza e
liberdade de que um estava com o outro
por escolha e por amor e é esse convite
que eu faço a vocês porque eu acredito
de verdade que a justiça é muito mais
justa
quanto mais afeto você coloca na justiça
não quanto mais afeto quanto mais
liberdade maior a possibilidade da gente
conseguir justiça
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]